[Musique]
on va passer au cloud gueule du jour
c'est les dessous de la rupture entre
pagaille a dit alors je rappelle
l'histoire paga donc vous êtes à cadix
ya vous êtes mariés ou quoi en thaïlande
mais vous êtes mariés ont réussi à lise
et en france la corse brûle fils ali
vous êtes connu dans les marchés ou des
langues tout à fait dans les marchés
aient reconnu quand il a essayé oui
c'est ça vous connaissez ma ration tout
à fait y arrive ça fait que maintenant
vous êtes ensemble à faire trois ans 3e
tour on vous en parlait vendredi vous
avez trompés a dit y a du coup dans les
marseillais le ration super tendu entre
deux regarde que nous tous les ciels et
marseille ou pas on va essayer de vous
décryptez 7 secondes et vous dire si
c'est du pipeau pas pour nous juste pas
gars on peut pas s'embrouiller avec sa
meuf ans tata et j'ai vu l'amener à
coussins après sur cette athènes sais
pas si vous avez remarqué
on n'a pas le droit on remarque donc
j'ai mis du scotch on met attendre oui
c'est même on peut pas s'embrouiller ans
tata n'est pas un petit est ce qui a
fait que cette dispute et pipeauté
est-ce que vous avez des infos et pas
garde vous nous direz après qui a des
infos qui a des infos qui va gagner
bonjour non mes addictions à la
production avait prévenu qu'il se
passait quelque chose avec paga
effectivement elle savait pas quel
savoir exactement mais oui avant de
venir elle savait qu'ils avaient un bon
tournoi
alors s'ils reconnaissent que ça a été
de la mise en scène dans l'unique but de
faire le buzz des toits vérité personne
à kasenyi vous qui connaissez bien un
truc par des vacances moi je connais pas
les verser mais honnêtement c'est très
mal joué excuse moi si elle le sait
avant la banon que tu l'a trompée
pourquoi tu lui dis pourquoi tu te
dévoile comme devant les caméras
franchement tu vie qu'elle est et quel
hacker la décrépitude hic manqué là une
mauvaise couleur de cheveux y avait plus
de sport pourquoi tu fais tout ça c'est
bien s'est jamais excusé moi si tu aime
quelqu'un et croyons qu'on croit moi
j'ai divorcé quatre fois dont il fait le
résultat est toujours personne situe à
occuper les terrains lui dis pas qu'elle
est moche et débute ce sport qu'elle a
grossi et qui ressemble plus à rien
honnêtement ça c'est pas du buzz
qu'est ce que c'est esclave affranchi
alors l'avouera pas parce qu'évidemment
il n'a pas avoué son salaire et je peux
le comprendre tout ça c'est par contre
elle a pas loin de dire et il a raison
maintenant il faut comprendre que ces
gens là c'est normal il eu de saison en
saison
en général le genre de prendre leur dit
voilà on a un peu fait le tour du
personnage et on leur fait comprendre
que si tu veux dans la saison suivante
ça serait bien qu'il se passe quelque
chose
si vraiment il amoureux évidemment qui
va pas annoncer aux la mise à sa copine
alors que j'ai trois ans qu'il en a qui
sont ensemble
tout d'un coup je t'es trompé donc
évidemment que ça a été créée la
production leur a demandé de faire ce
petit peu cela ça marche la preuve on en
parle il faut
moi ça me choque pas l'été des réalités
il faut qu'ils aient un scénario ghana
toujours mais bien évidemment que c'est
une peau alors maxime gaignard
combattants on va le foot c'est pas du
buzz c'est la classe academy canton
interview les producteurs les diffuseurs
est candidat tout le monde dit que ce
n'est pas jouer qu'il n'y a pas de
scénario certes vous êtes stimulé par
des situations des lieux des rencontres
également mais force est de constater
que les clashs réunis et vous permet de
réunir beaucoup d'audience hier par
exemple un million et un million de
téléspectateurs de locarno gérard
suivant j'étais abasourdi vous qui êtes
en vo j'ai dit mais roméo et juliette
c'est du pipi de chat c'est une scène à
la gelée vu la zes ans qui n'était pas
bien mon pauvre ami
il n'était pas bien manger rare il
n'était pas bien je suis tu je trouve
fait oui c'est bref mon pad à
du coup la vérité du coup la vérité mon
bagage
est ce que c'est vrai ou est ce qu elle
était au courant est ce que vous allez
vous vous êtes revenus ensemble ou pas
tout à fait elle lui a pardonné
c'est très difficile en ce moment bah
oui c'est normal vitrine à kingston il
faut faire le canard faire le koala et
pour revenir c'est franchement c'est pas
du fake vraiment je pouvais le dire ok
et à pâtisser il ya rien qui est
scénarisé après certes le producteur
c'est le business de voir du hainaut le
produit arrive à te voir
bagapch a pris la bonne décision pas
mais à aucun moment il te met le couteau
sous la gorge mais ils vous disent que
va son avis le couteau sous la gorge
fait une prise de judo d'entrée au moins
on en parle plus mais agace que vous lui
avez dit noter quelques cas relevés
balladur a sonné à ce que la bulle quand
même et c'est on vous l'a dit de lui
dire ces termes là non mais ça n'est pas
dans mon couple depuis depuis six mois
je vais pas dire j'avais la nation non
pas du tout l'abbé ouais je sais pas dit
que ces écoutes je t'es trompé mais on
sera ensemble non je lui explique
pourquoi les raisons je n'avais plus de
séduction et j'avais plus rien avec
cette fille et la lexus est revenu là
parce que j'étais à coire les aime à
pardonner elle a reconnu ses erreurs
alors aucun numéro un petit changement
qui sans pet mois change de couleur de
cheveux tout les mois je me serais pas
vraiment aux abymes au papy peau à
l'empa pipeau non non et là vous allez
reprendre et c'est vraiment la femme de
votre vie c'est la femme de ma vie
away dont rêvent les adama modi avec des
petites escale ouais non non c'est la
femme va laisser la fin de travaux qui
efface dirk kuyt et non parce que si
c'est la femme de ta vie
alors même si alain petit écart de sport
dans l'ansa tient aussi à cession
atteint sûr on sait que les images
montrent ce qu'ils veulent ah d'accord
mais après on est filmé 24 sur 24 et
j'ai pas dis que ça j'ai par du thé chez
ta couleur du cheval ils ont garé devant
le plus sulfureux ou est ce qui va faire
tenir le spectateur
j'espère qu'après tout ce qui était
championnat les primes je l'avais dit je
t'aime je te jure je lève la main droite
ouais non j'ai pas tricher on nous dit
j'ai pas très cher et pas très bien je
voudrais pensent les téléspecteurs est
ce que fait qu'à 57 % pas fake à 43 pour
la 6e
elles attendent avance parce qu'il ya
quand même dit était parti avec une plus
jeune était subi c'est un sondage mais
c'est vrai donc exactement très bas mais
régis bogaert tout cas il a répondu pas
d'art